this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house hi you bad
[__] it's monday the 18th of
july
the joint is brought to you by manscape
listen we're introducing
the ultimate hygiene bundle which means
we're introducing something that'll make
you [__] be a human being the
platinum package 4.0 manscaped is a
leader and below the waist grooming
support the show by going to
manscape.com right now
the platinum package includes little
more 4.0
this [__] is a savage you got to
trim your [__] around your nut sack
and your dick they got the weed whacker
for your ear and your nose then we got
ultra premium body wash to shampoo the
conditioner
the ultra premium deodorant we have
nutsack conditioner and we have crop
preservative
anti-chafing ball deodorant and crop
reviver ball spray toner
that's a deal in itself the lawnmower
4.0 body trim and weed whacker
it's going to make you look [__]
tremendous and they're waterproof
with the ultimate body wash and premium
201 shampoo you're going to be tip top
magoo
plus a little cologne
for set to go you understand me
manscaped has even thrown in two gifts a
travel bag which is tremendous a little
zipper inside and manscape boxes get 20
percent off and free shipping
with code joey at manscape.com again
that's code joey at manscape.com
for the platinum package you'll be tip
top magoo ready for somebody to sniff
your nut sack
the joint is also brought to you by
blue chew
listen
confidence can take you far in life like
me i'm an ugly dude but i got confidence
it could also help you in the bedroom
there i got no compliments that's where
blue chew comes in and makes that dick
harder than [__]
i don't know harder than what bluetooth
is an online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in a chewable tablet all at a
fraction of a cost
take them any time and be ready whenever
an opportunity arises the process is
simple sign up at blue chew consult one
of their licensed medical providers once
you're approved you get the prescription
in the mail
in days the best part is it's done
online no [__] video looking at you
creepy no awkward conversations no
waiting online for the pharmacy and
bluetooth tablets are made in the u.s.a
and shipped right to your house in the
discrete package so nobody knows dick
not even your mother you could benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
sling dick with blue chew
try blue chew for free joey what the
free using promo code joey j-o-e-y
just pay five dollars for shipping
bluechew.com with code joey for your
first month is free are you kidding me
once you do the manscaping the blue chew
who's better than you nobody so visit
bluetooth.com
pressing code joey and get five dollars
just pay five hours for shipping without
further ado let's get this [__]
party started jack
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
here we are for another monday edition
of uncle [__] joey's joint it's
the 18th of july
[__] great week it's gonna be hotter
than [__] this week so double powder
that nut sac because it's gonna be
[__] hot it was hot yesterday on
sunday
today's gonna be it's supposed to be
[__] like 90 to [__] friday so
you won't see me outside i'll be in the
pool all [__] week but it was a
great weekend i had a great time last
week i hit my thursday spot again little
commitments become big commitments
and uh
i did thursday night uncle venice it was
[__] great
with uh
i forget what her name is sheila mason
and uh
natalie cuomo [__] great i had a
great time but
while i was there i noticed something
and it [__] [__] me up for like two
days it really did it [__] me up
you know whatever happened the last two
years i don't want to harp on it
whatever the [__] happened the last two
years we forgot a lot as americans like
we forgot a lot of [__] things you
know
and
i forgot a lot of things that brought me
[__] joy like i had a lot of little
things that
you know it's not reefer it's maybe
hanging out my daughter or something but
the things that i enjoyed like my little
[__] things
i went down that thursday i followed
natalie cuomo i had a good set you know
i just [__] around and then i watched
when sheila got off there was only 50
people in the audience maybe 60 people
so it gave me a chance to sit in the
audience
and watch live comedy again
holy [__]
holy [__] now
you're going but joey you were just on a
tour
joey you were just with rogan in
atlantic city i'm sure you sat and
watched them
guys
i don't like arena tours
i don't like
stadium tour like for me what works for
uncle joey like what works me when i'm
watching music i wouldn't mind
seeing [__] slash you know in a
stadium or
you know a big time draw i don't care
but for comedy for some reason it's
never worked for me hey
it works for everybody else it doesn't
work for me in the sense that
when you watch comedy around 40 people
that's as pure as it can be
like we have forgotten that like
and i listen i'm like you i want to see
the bill burrs his new specials [__]
great from red rocks i want to see the
rogans you know i want to see the
[__] tom poppers and [__]
but here's the problem with that
i think that over the years even with me
like i [__] when i do a theater and
[__] it's like things get lost in
translation the bigger
the forum is you know what i'm saying
like i saw
def leppard and uh
acd seeing judas priests in venues that
people would kill to see people today
for us yes that's how music
was supposed to be done 1800 seats in a
little theater intimate sperm on the
floor you know
who gives a [__] you know i'm saying
like who gives a [__]
you're enjoying the energy of this
[__] band whoever that may be i
really don't give a [__] but it's a
smaller type situation again you're
talking to somebody who went to madison
square garden to see ted nacy dc or
black sabbath i felt i was in the right
venue for them but it would have been
better in the palladium but i'm not
complaining now you kick it outside
right when we're in uh
when we're at the [__] uh
the garden we're inside 18 000 seats 19
000 whatever when we go
let's take that same party into a
football arena you double the people
and it's outside
like you have uh no roof so the the
sound goes out for a guy like me that's
half [__] death
it's just it's an uncomfortable
situation i'm just i'm not even watching
the comic i'm watching the screen
okay it's like going to a ufc
and you get the the first 10 [__]
rows you're sitting next to boss root
and you got that guy over there but if
you look at all them all of them like
this looking at the [__] screen
because if you're looking at the cage
the cameras in front of them the reps in
front of you all this stuff in front of
at night listen great seats you could
smell the sweat you could smell the
tears you could smell the blood it's
phenomenal
but like the best seats i ever had were
with ari up in the middle where we could
see straight down and [__] with the
ass and anderson [__] silver kicked
what's his name in the jaw knocked him
out the ass made me actually say wow
like i saw the pow i was like holy [__]
it was like a batman effect but no man
you know it's like going to him it's
like going to a drive-in
or driving is great mike's in the back
lee's in the back we're eating edibles
we're passing a joint around we're
eating [__] popcorn from 1973.
we got the [__] thing in the window
like the little [__] thing in the
window the sound a little [__] up but
you're with your friends and you'll
probably have to watch that movie again
at some [__] time do you see what i'm
saying so
i've always been a fan of the smaller
venues i've always been a fan of open
mics
like yeah it's great to go see led
zeppelin it's great to go see the cars
it's great to go see corrosion of
conformity or [__] uh
you know but it's also nice to just
go to a [__] open mic like the one
mike plays out of the monday
when everybody's running around with a
chicken without a head and
you know a guitar string might blow up
you know what i'm saying
and that's the entertainment
not for you to leave and go i went to an
open mic
and the [__] band sucked
you know
obviously not like that you didn't go
for that
now you're gonna go back you're gonna do
an experiment you're gonna go back in
six weeks you're gonna look at the
roster and go when is this band back and
you're gonna go ch see him in six weeks
and see what the adjustments they made
that's i like all that [__] that i like
that whole [__] creativity [__] so
i i just
i didn't want to go home and i said let
me go out there because when an audience
is packed
like if i if if i do a show and met
fultron's opening or dean delray or
jimmy or any of my friends i want to
watch them but guess what i can't
because if i go out there some guy's
going to come up to me and go can i take
a picture hey joey what and i'm like hey
guy
i'm i'm i'm appreciative that you want
to talk to me but that's the guy that
you got to be paying attention to not me
so i can't even go watch my friends like
i went out to watch rogan for two
minutes and some guy grabbed me
you know and i'm like i can't do this
because you disrupt
that area so you're disrupting that area
and you're being disruptive to the
[__] comedian up on stage so if
you're at a comedy show and you see me
and i'm watching the headline i'm not
gonna take a [__] picture of you let
him [__] do his set and afterward we
could chit chat and talk but anyway
when i went out there the other night
there was nobody there so i just sat
there and i'm like wow this is [__]
great but i gotta be honest with you
i was mesmerized
for 12 minutes
for 12 minutes i hung on every word of
sheila's i watched her
i watched her mannerisms i watched her
take tells
i watched all her little things and it
was [__] great
you know the last time i [__] did
that i'll tell you when the last time i
[__] did that
maybe january of 2020 my goal every week
was to slip down to the store
on a tuesday night or maybe even like a
saturday night like i used to if i was
home on a saturday i loved that [__] i
would call the store for a 9 30 set i
would close the original room early i
still got my set in and i'm still home
by [__] 9 30
but i would go at 7 15
talk to the waitresses a little bit and
i would go in that room at 7 30 or 7
whenever the [__] it started and i would
watch the first eight comedians i'd put
like a little hooded shirt on a little
hooded sweatshirt and i'd sit in mitty
choice
chairs and i would watch whoever
i didn't give a [__] who it was i would
have just sit there sometimes allie wong
but then as the knight grew up you know
as the night got later somebody would
come and they want to have a
conversation about something i'm go [__]
now i can't watch this [__] you
can't have a conversation either you're
paying attention to the [__] comic
i would get super stoned i mean i would
do like four bong hits before i left the
house
and a joint in the back of the comedy
store and i would walk in there with the
water and just
learn
watch observe
you know see the things that are going
on in the [__] room
what else is going on while they're on
stage i'm watching the waitresses i'm
watching how they drop their drinks you
know on the table like when they not
drop their drinks but drop their drinks
to the customers i'm watching all this
and it's [__] tremendous
it's [__] tremendous
now in my world where i come from like
the best was the houston laptop when i
was a [__] feature act i would go to
houston and i would stay on monday
nights to perform because it was the
best night of the week coke was flying
it was a [__] party but
i would open mic watch the comics
i would watch the [__] comics and i
would watch them and study them even if
they had been doing comedy for two years
because watching sometimes is as
important as doing i don't want you to
tell me oh no no
listen i love watching specials and i
learned stu and stand-up comedy from
watching a couple specials i can still
[__] tell you which specials i watch
that's not the point the point was
live comedy so many things happen like
that's why i like
i don't like guys who stick to their
material all the time because [__]
happens in the room
whether somebody slips you're going to
keep talking about your aunt the fat
chick the [__] donate pineapple or
whatever they don't want to hear about
that the audience wants you
to address what just happened in that
[__] room not so much in music right
the music you don't stop your ukulele
and go hey
look at this guy he fell down you can't
do that but with stand-up comedy people
want to feel
in the moment i love preparing jokes
love them
but i also want to be there and i know
that if something happens in the room or
i get a reminder i can throw a [__]
audible in there
i could draw a different story in there
about the situation that's going on and
whatnot so
i was just blown away that night on the
way home i remembered how much i enjoyed
i forgot about how much i enjoyed life
come and what we're going to do the last
couple of years we all got stuck in the
house watching specials so i got caught
watching specials for a long time
and i got to tell you man
i'm not going to watch the special again
because i realized how much i enjoyed
that live
comedy not in a big [__] way not like
400 people no
i'm talking about when you're going one
of those nights and there's 40 people
and there's 10 comics and maybe five of
the comics aren't up to your standards
they're just getting started but even
watching them is [__] there was a guy
i think the most i ever learned as a
comic was watching
the open mic in seattle seattle
came into my life because denver was
okay but it was such a big time club
that they put on like uh
you know the comics that were really
rocking and rolling they didn't put on
the early guys unlike i like to do i
like to mix the guys i've been doing
comedy two years unless in the mix don't
put them up one after the other because
then you're gonna have a [__] up show
for four or five comics
so you want to get them involved in the
mix with you and those are the comics
that i enjoy watching when they [__] up
this one comic used to go up every
monday and he would do seven minutes
on impersonations
like this is my impersonation of michael
klein
did you enjoy it
this is my impersonation of joey diaz
did you like it
like that's what he would do that was
seven minutes of that every monday this
is mike this is my impersonation of
cosby hmm
did you like it
and after like 10 weeks i used to watch
him there was a couple there was a guy
that used to put a handcuff on
and go up on stage and say he was you
know these are the guys you want to
these are the guys you want to watch and
the sad thing is these are the guys that
eventually kill themselves i mean
not not in a bad way there was a comic
up in seattle i always had the handcuff
on i forget what his name was he was a
sweet sweet guy
when you had a conversation with him you
knew he was little butts you know what
i'm saying
there was a couple comics up there in
seattle especially where i learned that
mental health it's like rudy sarzo says
mental health and entertainment are at a
[__] fine line right there and i know
mike could attest to this there's some
[__]
crazy people in the music business
and there's some crazy people in the
open mic business okay
crazy people and those are the people i
live for i love those
misfits i was a misfit at a [__] open
mic wait i think i went up there
and was rocking and rolling it takes
like two [__] years to rock and roll
you're just going down there to get
[__] abused that's it when you're an
open mic prepare to get [__] abused
and you go down and you do the best you
can and that abuse
teaches you how to cope with all that
[__]
so it you know at the end you'll go oh
now i know i got abused all those years
now i'm enjoying knowing that i got
[__] abused you know so that's what
those first two years are
but i would enjoy watching like there
was a [__] tran sexual
that's right
we already had a transsexual up in
seattle in 1995.
and guys
i used to study her to the t because she
or him or i i don't know
she used to go up there and threaten the
audience that she was going to show him
that cut off dick he was in a jar
you know it was it was insane she'd have
no dick in her jaw
she [__]
she would go up there i i don't know
what she was talking about but she would
break it down
about transgenders and all that stuff
like that it was [__] tremendous if i
could bring rita o back today i would
rita oh god bless her soul i love the
daily she was the ugliest human being
i ever met she looked like one of the
devils behind the cover of sabbath
bloody sabbath if you if you ever
[__] see cyber bloody sabbath
well
yeah look you see the front ah this
one's just missing the back
the front
is like uh
it's these locusts see
it's like these devils and [__] the back
is really
a guy
saying goodbye to his family like if the
picture got ripped off because [__]
i put it up on the wall with crazy glue
or something when i ripped it down the
[__] album rip but the back of the
album is [__] uh
is uh a family saying goodbye to that
[__] loved one and then the front is
when the devil comes to your house and
takes your [__] soul those little
devils that's what rita oh look like
sorry about that
but she looked like she had pointy ears
and short hair
she looked like the kid that shot
everybody in [__] chicago two weeks
ago she looked a little like that
she had the [__] uh
she had the [__] uh what do you call
that stuff like not tattoos but she had
like no bangs
and your hair just went straight down
and that was it
that was her little that was a little
[__] she was a man she showed me a
picture when she was a man and i don't
know which picture was uglier the one
when she was a man was she was a woman
now when i say these things to you
people i loved rita oh rita o
lent me money one time help me with
[__] head shots i love rita oh so i'm
not saying nothing bad about rito what
i'm saying was that
she was not a good looking person at all
i mean at all and she was like five foot
two and she would always fall and that's
what she because the head was really big
when they made the operation
you know they keep your big head that's
why i would never work with a [__]
operation because
look at the size of my head you can't
shorten my chin you can't take a little
off the sides you know what i'm saying
what are you gonna do scrape the [__]
skull so as a woman i'd have this big
[__] head and my balance would be off
this is how she died rita oh i'm not
trying to be cute here i'll [__] call
josh wolfe right now and have him tell
you how she died rita oh constantly fell
if you didn't see rita oh at the open
mic
it was because she [__] fell
somewhere because her equilibrium was
off so she would fall so she just kept
falling for and she would go to those
gay clubs i went with her to some of
those gay clubs a couple of times and
she would get up on the [__] boxes
and jump and sure enough an hour later
had to bring her home with ice packs and
[__]
one night we [__] went to do comedy
at this place man
i will never forget this as long as i
[__] live
it was 1996
she would get like pills and [__] from
the government because she was
officially handicapped
because of the trend the operation i
guess i don't know
so they would send all these [__]
pain pills and all this [__] and she
would snort coke as much as i did so
when i went to this open mic a bunch it
was me josh gavin
tayna manu brody we would take over
these [__] rooms and just go off in
seattle
so this one night we're going up there
and we throw rita o first
rita goes up there and she's up there
talking about [__] and all this [__]
and the owner [__] went right up on
the stage in this restaurant took the
mic from when he goes we must be clean
we are not a dirty comedy club and all
this [__] they didn't know what was
coming up after
this was just the appetizer of the night
one thing led to a [__] other and
[Music]
that we settled it we go ah she'll be
clean don't worry about nothing and the
guy's like okay okay it's a family
restaurant he gives rita all the mic she
starts blasting [__] jokes and [__]
and [__] the guy's losing his mind he
throws us all out but rita refuses to go
out in the night
softly she wants to get into a pushing
match with the [__] dude so now we're
pulling her we get her in the car she's
like [__] you nobody tell me what to do
i switch governments you know i do what
i want you know all this [__] we bring
her home and she still [__] thought
she's snorting coke and she's talking
about this guy banning how it's not
[__] legal and i'm like rita what do
you want me to do [__] call to pray
you know you just tell people what do
you want me to do reid i can't help you
here call the president if you want to
change the rules
she looked at me she goes
you don't think i won't
i will so at four in the morning this
[__] got on the phone and called the
white house
and when they answered she's like i want
to talk to the president i'm like
rita they're gonna trace that call and
they're gonna come back here and they're
gonna take away our drugs and they're
gonna [__] and she's like i don't
care
so she called clinton i don't know who
the [__] was president and she [__]
she kept calling them they hung up on
her and sure enough the next day the
cops came to a house yeah
but they didn't come at four in the
morning but they came to [__] next
day
all right anyway
last weekend i was talking about [__]
uh
cinema
you know and how much i love cinnamon
how much i miss it i obviously went to a
[__] movie monday with uh hari i
caught he's leaving this week if he
wasn't leaving tomorrow i'd say pick
another [__] movie let's just go see
something i want to get in that habit of
going to see a movie every week not a
new movie
something old and a ratty cinema that
smells like old farts you know i'm
saying two for one two movies for ten
bucks whatever that's what i'm into
anyway i talked about porn and star porn
i spoke about [__] cinema and all
this stuff and i got these interesting i
mean people i guess i'm not the only
cinema [__] addict out there
because people really responded to me
like people were like bro we feel the
same way baba
but i got a couple of [__]
interesting uh
emails and people like joey
and all the years of listening to you
i never really heard you talk about porn
you know were you uh
did you ever go to any porno houses or
anything like that
the answer is yes when i was
i don't know 16 17
there was a movie theater on sunday
nights maybe in teaneck 10 to fly
25 minutes from north bergen that showed
pornos and i i was a stupid kid
i was like [__] yeah i'll go see a
[__] porno movie
let me tell you something that was not
good
i don't know who sits in those [__]
portal houses all day
but that [__] was not good i went to
watch one movie
it you know it's one of those movie
theaters you go to the bathroom and
three guys pop out of the [__]
out of the [__] stalls to watch you
pee
like also you'll get a guy that has to
pee right here and the guy that has to
pee right there and they're both looking
at your dick and she's like come on guys
knock it the [__] off it was one of
those places in fact the reason why we
stopped going there was because a buddy
of mine got into an altercation in the
back when we [__] the guy up and we
had to run the [__] out of there there
were creepy people there on the weekends
i think i went maybe
it was sunday nights i went maybe two
times
and that was enough for me i am not a
porn guy guys i love eating ass i love
eating [__]
i love craziness but
uh i had two situations happen to me
that destroyed me out of the porn game
number one
uh when i was like 10 or 11 or 12 i
ordered pornos online you know not
online couldn't order [__] online
no you couldn't even order them on tv
you got to go to a playboy magazine and
go all the way to the back not even
playboy penthouse and those disgusting
magazines like you know
cherry was a cherry we were kids
that showed you like the girls [__]
kidneys and [__] i mean they were
disgusting
sherry was one of those magazines with
the cherry on the cover c-h-e-r-i
again i was never a big
porn magazine guy but
uh somebody gave me the
a porno you know you jerk off when
you're 11 or 10 whatever the [__] you do
and then uh
uh
you know you is it sherry yeah yeah
cherry magazine
you could put a little picture up during
the podcast jerry magazine uh there's
cherry right there he's over bruce lee
cherry magazine had all those things so
me and like five of my buddies sabatino
spash
we [__] chipped in like four bucks a
piece for 19
9.99
they sent you 3.0 and a little projector
[__] a projector for 19.95
you had to mail it to somebody's house
whose parents weren't going to be there
all day
uh
it was [__] crazy we waited about
seven weeks it was the longest seven
weeks of my life
because every [__] kid that chipped
in the four dollars was like [__]
where the [__] are my pornos guys i
don't know it's four to six weeks for
the [__] delivery so every day after
school we would run to my house and see
if the [__]
pornos had gotten there eventually they
got there one day so one day we had to
wait now to watch them i had to make
sure my mother was out of the [__]
state
you know you got to make sure your mom
is out of new jersey she's in new york
city she i couldn't take a chance with
just being up in the union city because
she would make a surprise attacks and
then shake me down and [__]
i told you my mom shake me down for like
10 [__] years every time she saw me i
had to turn around put my hands on the
wall and she'd [__] frisk me and the
whole thing
so
uh oh it was [__] tremendous
so uh
i don't know what the [__] i was talking
about so i we we watched this [__]
porn
it was like a hot hot hot summer day
my mom was going like a mech game or
some [__] i put aluminum fall on the
windows
we were up in the attic so we had to get
like a theater like a movie theater had
to be dark
we were up in the attic
because i had the door didn't really
have a door when you came up the attic
stairs it didn't have a door it just had
like uh it was no no door at all
so uh
we put the aluminum foil up i took a
sheet and thumbtacked it
because
we put it on the wall
i pushed the bed around so we could all
sit on the bed long ways
i i don't know i think i made sandwiches
and [__] and when that we all went up
there like liverwort sandwiches with
american cheese i [__] loved that
[__] in the summer and we made like
liverwurst sandwiches and one up there
guys it was the most disturbing
disturbing disturbing afternoon of my
life
okay
it this is this isn't the point that you
see now with i don't know a delivery guy
comes and you suck his dick no no this
is like a chick that was strong and
that's what it opened up with
just to check strong on heroin i could
live to be a hundred and i'll never
forget these first to eight minutes
she was strung out on something she was
skinny
she must have had a kid because she had
flapjack titties like it was the nipple
was the thickness of them it was not
bueno to look at guys
she had like burn marks on her somebody
was putting burn marks on it and i'll
never forget this like a [__] comedy
routine if i could find this tape today
i would [__] i would i would go up
there and just play it for 45 minutes
and narrate it and people would be
[__] entertained because this was
real disgusting pornography and the
chicks like all [__] up on i don't
know what and all of a sudden i know a
[__]
just pops out of the screen is coming
towards her
and she's like you know hi and whatever
she sees and she's like oh my god a cop
and and she's like looking and you could
hear the director going grab it
grab it like this is how bad this
[__] pawn was like rabbit crap were
like what the [__] and all of a sudden
she's like no she doesn't want to this
is all on tape and finally you just see
her grab the dick
and she starts sucking it and it's
disgusting the dick it's got burn marks
on it too they're probably from the same
burning community or whatever the [__]
she's sucking his dick and she's not
into it and we're like [__] kids so
we're like what the [__] is going on
here this is disgusting a dick in her
mouth we had never seen that i never
knew that that could even [__]
possible i started grabbing my little
dick like what the [__] what if she
bites it and [__] she's sucking the
guy's dick then you finally hit like the
director go cut or something and she
stops she's all [__] up and she's like
and the guy's like yeah whatever and all
of a sudden she just puts her hand and
he gives her two pieces of white bread
i'll never forget this guys she put the
two piece of white brown the guy's dick
then they give a miracle whip and she
puts miracle whip on his dick and she
starts biting the sandwich around the
[__] dick guys after the second bite
all three of us were probably like 12 4
of us was 12 but there was one 10 year
old i let him in because he chipped in
the five hours you know what i'm saying
dog this [__] started crying
that's how bad this pornography was
he just started i'm scared i want my
money back we're [__] dying of
laughter but at the same time i'm
[__] scared of this [__] what is this
putting bread on a guy's dick with
i don't know if it was miracle whip or
that [__] that that
what's that [__] disgusting [__] that
people
marshmallow stuff it was like that
marshmallow stuff and i'm like
marshmallows
i couldn't deal with that [__] so i
turned that [__] off and then
like yeah i'm a man i'm into titties at
church and [__] like that
and then my buddies took me to the 10 40
club and i saw a [__] waitress
that looked like she got hit by a
[__] bomb and she
she told me to give her to give her 10
bucks
she wanted 10 bucks to [__] for me to
eat a [__]
and i was like you're out of your
[__] mind i put my pants on i ran the
[__] out of that and that was my short
career in the porno life and now
for a word for my sponsors better help
listen you got to take care of your mind
a lot is going on in the world right now
we spend a lot of time taking care of
our skin our hair our teeth
but we forget about our brain how well
you take care of your brain affects how
you experience life
eating right working out getting plenty
of sleep they're great
but there's no substitute for talk
therapy better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and most
importantly affordable why is therapy
important
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions i started with them about nine
months ago
with a therapist called dana and it has
been a positive
i'm doing great
she got me some coping skills
she taught me how to deal with some of
my anxiety and some of the issues and
here we are it's much more affordable
and in-person therapy you're never gonna
you're never gonna get a face-to-face
therapist right now
that ship sales so you could be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
one that fits your needs and knows
exactly how to help you so do me a favor
joint listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
diaz
better help the smarter way to do
therapy
all right we're back sorry about that i
had to drop a little message for you
from better help
and uncle joe had to take a piss let me
tell you what happens to me okay when i
go to the gym early mornings
i must drink 60 ounces of [__] water
you got to remember i drink like [__]
i bring like a 48 ounce thing of water
with me with like carbohydrate powder in
it and then i got another water and i
put liquid iv in it so between this 16
ounces and the 48 that 60 [__] ounces
okay i'm ready to bust a [__] nut
so i'm very sorry about that but we had
to read better help anyway so i'm hoping
that you are using everything from
better help they're a great company
they help me and uh i feel great hey i'm
living [__] proof you saw me in the
transition so but anyway going back to
porn i mean those two situations
i don't know i was never a big porno guy
i have one playboy magazine in my house
it was given to me by sergio ortega on
facebook dear friend of mine for the
last 12 13 years we started beauty and
the beast
and i said one day that that was the
only playboy i wanted and he found it at
a [__]
i got a playboy magazine that's it i i
don't have penthouse i don't even know
where to get cherry i think they're out
of publication amazon has cherry
magazine
wow [__] amazon is stupid jack
but i i just was never i don't know i
was into
my wife says i'm a prude
and i think i believe that sometimes
like i'm i talk a lot of [__] but i'm
really a [__] prude i i don't like a
lot of things
that a lot of people like and enjoy
that's why when i heard a lot of things
saying about me i'm like obviously these
people don't know anything about me i'm
a regular guy i like to get my dick
sucked and have a great [__] time but
it's not what you guys think today i
always think about and i look around and
i think how people might feel and i felt
that way even as a child like i was like
i used to look at girls sometimes and go
how can a girl sleep with me
and then just go on with her life
like i never liked that like i was like
so we're gonna work together and then
i'm gonna give you a stabbing and then
we're gonna go back to work like nothing
happened
and it's never gonna be discussed i
always had [__] problems with that so
i was never a [__] porn guy and it's
weird when the people ask me like they
were like hey man you never talk about
[__] porn
i couldn't tell you i know tabitha
stevens
she's a porno chick a porn old lady with
dear friends i'm friends with her and
her husband i could look you
[__] in the eye and tell you
that i've never
seen her naked whatever picture she puts
on twitter i'll retweet for her you know
with and they're always covered felicia
michaels my dear friend my sister was in
playboy magazine i have never looked at
her spread
i've never looked at a spread i've never
found
i just i like it too much
i don't want to see what a [__] looks
like you know what i'm saying
i i know a lot of girls that aren't only
fans and [__] and i they'll say a lot of
comics especially will say it up on
stage if i get talking to them
i can't look at an only [__] they're
only fans before i started the patreon
a girl at the comedy store told me she
was not only fans
just to let you guys know
i thought she was topless but i also
thought they were doing jokes on there
and [__]
because only fans
made me an offer
like three years ago they were like
listen we want to put was it only fans
yeah it was only friends
are there still comics on there but
it's like mostly females
yeah they show tits and [__] that's what
happened when i joined this girl's
patreon
i don't mind looking at somebody's
titties and if she's cracking jokes or i
don't know what she was gonna put on
there when i went to it
it was her [__] boyfriend and i was
like
that's kind of wild it was hubble like a
ball in the [__] i was like you know
what i don't see her
she wasn't one of my dear friends it
wasn't like it was like whitney or eliza
or something like that i wouldn't look
at that [__] [__] either
but i just don't know it just made me
always feel
like i was cheating and then
this is why i'm bringing this up guys i
like to read a lot and i like to read
i like
listen if you're going through something
and you're like when i was a kid i when
i went to colorado i learned that well
i figured out that yeah i had great
friends i grew up with great friends and
there were good people and they'd give
me the [__] off their back and whatnot
but
sometimes your friends
don't help you expand your mind
you know what i'm saying like yeah
they'll help you [__] rob people and
they'll help you beat somebody up and
they'll help you get drugs and that's
great but expanding your mind open you
up to different things when i went to
bold i learned about that you know they
have to go outside your circle sometimes
to learn different things so i i always
went out you know guys i was a [__]
loser and i wanted a stro and i was
struggling
and i just wanted to get it right one
time when you keep trying when you're a
loser and you keep trying and you keep
failing it doesn't feel better even
though failure builds [__]
character but uh
i just didn't uh i i always tried to
put myself around people part time that
were smarter than me that i could learn
something from
and when i joined jiu jitsu i i
met a lot of intelligent [__] guys
because to be really good at jiu jitsu
you got to have a different mind you got
to look at things different eddie bravo
sees things different i know he sees a
flat earth also but disregard that
everything else is [__] solid with
that dude one of the guys that i love
with all my heart that's really
helped me a lot in the last couple of
years is nick gregorius
nick gregorius is uh the first black
belt from
hodger gracie
and uh
i started looking at his videos online
and i liked what he spoke about you know
he
he spoke about things that were
different he's spoken about opening up
your mind and you know
so i really started getting into him and
communicating with him when i got into
jiu jitsu he had a tremendous close
guard game
which that's what aj gracie teaches a
closed guard game and you know he said
he would come to
the jiu jitsu school and guess what he
came to the jiu jitsu school i was at
subconscious and today he's part owner
of subconscious i hooked him up with
brett that's one of the things i'm
really happy about between brett
and nick they've taught me so much about
life brett's another guy that's white
dude from indiana bad [__]
dangerous jiu jitsu guys if you're
looking for great jiu jitsu instruction
and you're in southern california i mean
there's a lot of it there's big schools
cabrini and [__] eddie bravo 10
planet and alberto cranes they're all
great schools but if you're looking for
a smaller school
where you get a lot of bang for your
buck uh i love subconscious i love nick
gregorius
nick sent me his book
a couple months ago and
i started just looking at chapters
reading through chapters
and i found the chapter that was [__]
interesting as [__]
so
i uh
read it and i found a couple chapters in
this book that were interesting as [__]
but there was one chapter in particular
that [__] stuck a chord with me if
you get a minute order the modern man's
guide to true health wealth and
fulfillment
it's uh
it's a great book
you know i've read the whole thing
he has a lot of interesting stuff in
there that you could take from we all do
you know nick
i'm not saying nick is like me i'm like
nick in a lot of ways i like doing human
experiments i'm myself yeah i've done
human experiments on people with edibles
and [__] like that
breaking the boundary you know breaking
the band
but
uh i do i do a lot of experiments you
know and this guy
is smarter than [__] and when i picked
up his book
i couldn't put it down but one of the
chapters i wanted to read for you if you
guys like porn or whatnot again i'm not
here to judge i don't give a [__] if you
[__]
you know me i don't give a [__] men just
imagine the enormous potential you could
unlock within yourself if your mind body
spirit and purpose we're all totally
optimized and working in harmony in a
line successor entrepreneur
nick gregory has 20 game changing
principles nick's a [__] great guy
but one of the chapters
that didn't
uh
apply to me but applied to what we were
talking about is
chapter seven
is called drop the porn
and it opens up with a zig ziglar
[__] line feed your mind with the
good the clean the pure
the powerful and the positive
uh around the same time i began to
meditate i began to develop greatly
increase self-awareness
specifically i became hyper aware of
people places and things that affected
my energy and the way i felt
in particular i started to notice that
each time i engaged with porn i felt
several negative effects
not only did i feel literally and freely
drained but i also noticed it was having
detrimental effects of my mood and
ability to concentrate
i watched a movie in 2013 called don
juan it follows the story of a guy who
develops
unrealistic expectations from watching
porn and cripples his ability to have a
healthy relationship
eventually he overcomes his addiction
and finds happiness
and true love all right
the dark side i want you to imagine
a spectrum of human experience on one
end
of the things most of us
interestingly regard as positive
composure contentment clarity
self-mastery and health on the other
side on the other hand are the
attributes and states of mind that we
view with disdain and seek to avoid
disconnect and patience impulsiveness
greed and confusion to me
almost any action or experience can be
located somewhere
in this spectrum porn hijacks the
circuitry of your brain
and causes you to become addicted to
sexual novelty and to subscribe
i don't know dopamine spikes released by
viewing it unfortunately you also become
very quickly desensitized to this
novelty and require more unusual or
extreme stimulus which is usually
accompanied by increased levels of
depravity depravity
porn feeds the urge for instant
gratification and fuels greed and excess
in this way it's destructive to the soul
a close friend of mine once worked with
someone let's call him steve who got a
job with one of the big pawn stypes
steve roe was to filter out
submitted videos for anything illegal or
too extreme
basically he watched porn all day and
got paid for it
well after a few months when my friend
saw steve again he was shocked at the
deterioration in his physical and
psychological state
my friend said all he kept thinking
about was that he reminded him of the
gollum from the lord of the rings
sickly and anxious he couldn't even look
me in the eye anymore
anyway we don't need to read this
anymore but it's [__] up
i've never
like i said i
i like [__]
i'm like you you know what i'm saying i
like big bits i like hair on them
i like looking at [__] i don't like
chicks sucking dick in front of me like
i've never been a big fan i don't want
to see some guy's dick
i don't know i never felt this way about
porn i just knew i didn't [__] like
it you know but i didn't know the reason
why i read that was because i didn't
know
it affected us as much as that i've
heard
[__] uh little noises over the years
of people having problems with porn or
addictive to porn or whatever like that
you know what man it's just uh
i don't know it just never fit my
[__] uh
who i was as a as a human being or
whatever
again if you go like playboy and you got
naked pictures on your wall i ain't mad
at you i was 13 once too i had a couple
of people i had a led zeppelin picture
and i'm under it like i it was a great
under it i had like a picture of a chick
with a [__] and she my mom never found
it she ended up my mom never found it
she didn't look under the posters she
died but if you get a chance man if you
could get this book
this is a great [__] book like i said
i've always been like a mild fan of
anthony robbins and those guys
i'm not gonna [__] walk on all that
[__]
but
uh he has some great stuff in here
minimize your alcohol use
realize it's not about the money
you know because he talks a lot in here
he's a buddhist in a way and he talks a
lot in here about
money and material things to happiness
what brings happiness and whatnot
and one of the things he talks about a
lot that i
i have now that i didn't have
five or six years ago is clarity
clarity is very [__] important you
know
self-awareness clarity where you stand
these are all the things that
i worked with for years and then i got
away from and then i went back from and
then i got away from but it all came
back in the laundry you know when you're
trying to better yourself and whatnot i
don't want you to
take these books to [__] art i want
you to take them
do the experiments i mean this guy
i love him because he even has a chapter
on sleep in here
and
again
i do some of these same things he says
that uh you know
optimize your testosterone
prioritize the sleep ritual okay
i remember reading this
tape your mouth that's a [__] good
one but you breathe a lot better you
know he takes sleep enhancing principle
sleeping hand enhancing supplements so
he goes from cbd to magnesium oil to lep
lemon bomb to zinc
to gaba don't take them all at once
because you'll have no idea what's
working for you and what is it instead
introduce them one at a time and that's
what i do also to see what the [__]
you're getting you're banging your butt
so i switch it around two nights i use
cbd lion the tincture
two nights i use [__] something i
don't want to use which is that [__]
uh nyquil without the alcohol that [__]
up your [__] what's that called
you're at you i don't know you sprinkle
you piss a lot in the middle of night
i'll go for the [__] uh melatonin and
magnesium i love melatonin
from [__] on it has great melatonin
you spray it under your tongue you know
what it's only going to work two or
three nights that's all that works on me
and then i have to put it back into a
[__] different situation
i'll tell you the delta eight cbd lion
delta eights put me to [__] sleep
i got a lot of [__] but i have to go
from night to night last week
nothing seemed to [__] work
guys i smoked i got no reason a lot of
you [__]
i think monday night i smoked three
joints back to back
i [__] ate everything in that kitchen
that's the morning i woke up and my
socks were in the kitchen
but i could not [__] fall asleep so
and then i realized that last week was a
full moon
it was a full moon
sunday monday and tuesday or something
like that so that's what didn't [__]
let me sleep what's a [__] full moon
but who gives a [__]
i'm happy about this week
i got two shows
i got [__] uh wednesday at uncle
vinnie so i got thursday at the stress
factory they're both sold out
i'm very happy about that i went from
doing one show a week now we go to
two shows a week you see how easy this
was
you see how easy this was
little steps become big steps people and
you take it from [__] there
but if you do everything all at once
you're gonna [__] crash and
it's the law diminishing returns i'd
rather come home at night and go [__] i
could have done another spot tonight
then go do it i just wanted to keep this
going for a couple weeks
just one spot a week this week i do two
i'm sorry i didn't see sam tripoli last
week
i had an id i thought sam tripoli was
here this [__] saturday the 21st
not the 15th so i [__] up i missed sam
some of my friends went out to see him
at the dojo comedy
and that was my [__] weekend guys you
know what i'm saying i'm just trying to
keep it consistent
i'm not going over my head i don't know
if you guys uh read the news this
morning or on sunday morning
[__] craig robinson was on stage in
north carolina he was about to go up and
a gunman came in
and shot
uh
fired shots in the club and they all had
to evacuate the [__] club
like i tell you people all the time
watch yourselves
watch people i'm not telling you to stay
home and [__] your life up because
you're scared of a gunman that's never
gonna [__] work all i'm asking you to
is a human being
keep your eyes open guys don't get too
[__] up in public those days are gone
remember when i used to tell you
[__] that you don't go out on
new year's and get [__] up because you
want to pay attention
guys it's getting to the point now
where you got to do this seven days a
week
you want to have a few drinks out
have a few drinks out but you don't want
to get hammered out no more because you
never know what's going to happen and
you want to be aware for every [__]
thing but when somebody comes in with a
gun to a [__] comedy club
i get concerned and i hope you guys get
concerned i'm not telling you to go buy
a gun or a bulletproof vest those are
things not to do
i'm just telling you
to keep your eyes open
pick your [__] destinations
intelligently and uh
because i tell you what it might cause
me to go see [__] cheap trick and i
get shot in the head i'm gonna be laying
there bleeding going i can't believe i
died going to see chip trick i [__]
hate cheap trick now if i got shot in
the head going to see [__] sabbath i
wouldn't give a [__] but led zeppelin
but can you imagine going to see getting
shot in the head over some [__]
shitty band or some shitty party you
didn't want to so
pick your [__] spots
[__] uh
intelligently and that's it and that's
that i love you [__] with all
my art i had no idea what i was talking
about today but hey it made sense and i
had a good time what we covered today
don't watch
porn [__]
or watch porn and lose your [__] mind
i love you [__] i'll see you
wednesday
morning tip top magoo ready to go
i'll if not i'll see you at the stress
factory or at uncle vinnie's
on wednesday have a great monday
i love you [__] and now for a
word for my [__] sponsors
all right i want to thank yous for
coming on today on a beautiful [__]
monday don't forget the part of your
nuts it's gonna be hot but now
better help is the way to go listen we
had a rough couple years
we started down mine started going in
different directions and now it's time
to pay the piper and who better than
better help better help makes online
therapy accessible convenient and
affordable
why is therapy important the way the
world's going today guys
it's not bueno and we gotta process
all the stuff that's getting thrown at
us better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions
you could choose to see anybody or
nobody and it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy
joint listeners can get up to ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
dies d-i-a-z
that's betterhelp.com
diaz
better help real therapy at a third of
the cost the joint is also brought to
you by blue chew listen confidence can
take you far in life
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis take them any time
and be ready to sling dick and sick the
ship sink the ship when the opportunity
arises process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
consult one of their licensed medical
providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it it's all done online nobody knows
dick
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they get shipped right discreetly to
your house nobody knows not even that
[__] nosy mailman
you could benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform blue chew can
help i'm sure you got a good strong dick
but might not make it the best there is
out there try blue chew for free when
using promo code joey just pay five
dollars for shipping that's
bluetooth.com
code joey for your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more important
safety information the joint is also
brought to you by [__] manscape
listen
i've been telling you about manscape for
years and years they're tremendous and
it's july if you still haven't trimmed
around your nut sack and your pogo stick
i don't know what the [__] to tell you
manscape is the leader and the below the
waist grooming they got a thing called
the platinum [__] package it's a 4.0
lawnmower trimmer a weed whacker for
your nose hair and anywhere else you got
creepy hair coming out of and then they
got deodorant shampoos crop preservers
anti-chafing ball deodorant crop ball
spray tone listen
we got you covered your balls are the
ugliest part in your body and manscape
is there what the [__] are you waiting
for
manscape is even throwing in two free
gifts manscape boxes and a travel bag
with the platinum 4.0 package who's
better than you nobody get 20 percent
off and free shipping
with code joey at manscape.com that 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
i want to thank manscape i want to thank
betterhelp
and i also want to thank bluetooth but
most importantly i want to thank you for
always having our backs here at the
joint stay black have a great [__]
day and i'll see you wednesday tip top
magooy
[Music]
you